so
so
so
foreign
so
so
so
so
now you should be able to hear me
how'd you like the
the the weather effects man the weather
effects how'd you like it
you know i got to keep you guys on your
toes
i got to be spontaneous
let me check everything right now
obviously we're going to be reacting
to ubisoft
all right
lord rainstones nah it's not that
serious it's not that serious
three more years
i'm not crying you're crying made me
want to go to the bathroom and pee i
hear you man
we got people still coming
they'll be here momentarily
gotta set up the
the
nice t-shirt oh you like it
my dragon ball z shirt
yeah
no i'm good thank you
got the ubisoft show right here
we're already in the right place
apparently there's a pre-show guys
hold up let's let's let's get you guys
in here man
there's a pre-show
okay what is going on
all right so
you gotta love technology sometimes man
it's duplicating
the zoom so i'm gonna have to
redo a screen capture to make sure that
it's a new source
like this
um
bam gotta be a little bit more reserved
so i got some people coming
thank you guys enjoy the
the people i have chosen to come here
king will be here eventually
let me redo the desktop audio
why isn't desktop audio showing up
oh there it goes because now you can
visit ubisoft can you guys hear me find
walkthroughs collaborations with your
favorite creators and exclusive tips
curated by the developers themselves all
of this is created to help you get the
most out of your game whether it's brand
spanking new or a seasoned classic
find game plan on youtube
in game and online to gain the
confidence of an assassin and the skill
of a champion level operator look at
look at this [ __ ] by sam fisher to the
left
wonder if that's going to incentivize
something
i don't know
as a child
let's get off the ign let's find like
my enemy
ubisoft thing
let's actually go to ubisoft
i feel like that would be the correct
thing to do what's up post up
something has awakened in the mire
glowing eyes watching the night
shadows slither through the woods
and twisted cackles taunt us
brave samurai venture into the swamps
but what comes back
it isn't them
a deadly web has been woven and there is
no escape
my teachings were wrong
only fools
don't fear the dark
uh
trying to
give us a little bit of a stream
all right so right now this is how we're
gonna do it
for honored yeah
ah be nice to post though be nice to
post up guys if you're just joining us
you're watching the ubisoft forward
pre-show in just a little bit we'll have
more exciting news and trailers about
our upcoming releases to share with you
before we get to this amazing lineup we
still have a couple more announcements
check this out shall we let's do it
until ubisoft forward
go ahead and post on twitter that we
live man hello everyone there's some
people in this scene
for many years now we've been working
with indie studios from across the world
there's been mentoring there's been
funding
to showcase some game from studios we've
had the privilege of working with
enjoy oh hi there i'm mikko i'm one of
the founders of skyward entertainment we
are skyward entertainment based here in
helsinki finland we are currently
working on a game called second stone it
will be a nostalgic mashup combining
your back to the roots classic action
rpg with super tight platforming
gameplay in second stone players will be
drawn into this vast and beautiful world
filled with adventure and excitement
however everything is not as it seems
there is a dark twisted parallel
universe that hides right in front of
your eyes and only you can get there
you will experience a thrilling and
mind-bending story that unravels these
secrets of this hidden realm one piece
at a time to make your journey as fun as
possible in second stone we are working
really hard in perfecting the gameplay
with satisfying tactical combat combined
with state-of-the-art character
progression systems reason that you know
we're seeing a little bit before
everyone gets
for instance by providing a very
detailed and professional review of our
game pitch and demo this helped us
tremendously in taking second stone
towards the right direction already like
early on thank you all for watching and
please feel free to join us at skyward
entertainment.com for more second stone
okay
hello my name is kim and i'm the ceo of
unreliable narrators a montreal-based
studio dedicated to creating games that
empower the voices of those that too
often go unheard we're currently hard at
work on our very first project in
narrative driven games that in 17th
century canada called two falls two sets
of tracks oh wow
we're incredibly lucky to be in montreal
where ubisoft has been well established
for now 25 years and a very active force
in the gaming ecosystem and we're really
happy to have won the national i can't
hear you at it
we also got marketing business and
technical advice on the ubisoft
entrepreneurial division yeah you should
be able to hear me it's on you i think
you're muted
whose people have become afflicted by a
strange illness as the name of our
studio suggests nothing is quite as
obvious
through branching and impactful dialogue
options light investigation mechanics
and wonder at the world around them
players will piece together the
mysteries surrounding our two characters
two falls is currently set to release on
pc in the fall of twenty twenty three
seasons
please wish this a game on steam or give
us a follow on twitter thank you so much
waiting for the rest of the
the crew to get here i'm invited by the
way that's not all three starting right
now
you can play indie games on ubisoft plus
our subscription service and it just so
happens to be free to try this month so
go ahead let me out let me send one to
uh
oh what is that oh fail seal
hold up we got to go back a little bit
guys let me see what
what is going on here
i reviewed that felt so
where is everybody watching on
um
i don't really care
watch it on twitch is better
oh the crew
i'm surprised this game is still around
the emails on screen having you though
huh your email is on screen
inbox
um
[Applause]
faster
this is uh
i will say this is mad as well
i mean it's still like racing things
that maybe that's just me i just don't
like racing things
hello everyone motor flicks welcomes you
back mason
mason your incredible experience
alongside the forsberg team prepare to
enjoy a whole new episode
get ready to face a winter or fury
performance driving on all terrains
that's how things move this season
yeah prince of persia could be here
prepare to enjoy a whole new episode
the dominion frozen
1986 brittany france the game what the
hell is going on
only creative minds ready to shape i
guess you
when the first assassin's creed game
came out in 2007 he knew it could
develop into a passion and become a
major part of his life and at first he
wondered if he should take the leap of
faith indeed when i get passionate i
throw myself 100 into things so i'd
rather think twice in the end he did and
ac pierre and ubisoft would go on quite
an adventure together
here it is kind of crazy what assassin's
creed's turned
immediately it was a trailer that got
him hooked no not this one
not this one either
still wrong it was a finite trailer in
2010
i watched it and then i immediately
showed up at my neighborhood yeah and i
played it change your name okay mega
people can't see your name yet
he loved the story he loved the
aesthetic the universe he'd never
traveled that much with any other game
i'm not going to drag it down until you
change cosplay
he crafts and wears beautiful costumes
based on the fictional worlds he loves
so he saw huge potential
the universe of ac was a playground in
which i started to feel very creative
you're here for free is a really
different yeah but change your nation
your real name is in the biggest reward
oh sure was one of the
he did miss the chance to get an ac
hoodie at gamescom one year right now
they can't see the bottom of the moon
put him on the radar i'm not changing it
to you
where do i go to change that let me
click right
affirmative
it's quite a lot of trust
there we go
at this stage his passion had evolved
into a lifestyle pierre was stuck on ac
and ac was literally stuck on him he
wrote and shot a whole web series he
organized fan events where he
orchestrated quizzes and contests he
never missed an opportunity do you
remember eve oh yes i remember
ubisoft wants a community ambassador at
e3 in los angeles
clear the way people here you don't hear
the feedback from my tv do you it was a
dream come true okay
i met more people many from ubisoft and
i finally felt like my commitment was
recognized
at this point pierre had unlocked every
challenge as a player and a community
leader what achievement could he try to
earn next
pierre had a new dream to be part of the
teams at ubisoft bringing ac to life
over seven years in five applications he
tried to join ubisoft he waited and
hoped never losing sight of his goal
that's a very long time pierre what kept
you motivated
well i had a bit of perspective and
explored new things but i stayed
positive and passionate
positivity and perspective are great
yeah sometimes you just i have no clue
how long this happens
right john
whoa that's pretty deep
you think it will be about the same
length as uh the disney showcase
maybe a little longer because they might
be a little more
yeah they might have a lot more show
and that's how pierre's dream came true
he finally joined ubisoft today pierre
is a project manager in the advocacy
team i build bridges and relationships
between the ubisoft brands and the fans
since joining ubisoft pierre has of
course found a new way of building
community around another one of his
passions light i mean laser savers
but the circle cannot be complete
without this slight but significant
detail
you remember this one
as his first manager when we changed job
now we were no longer working together i
wanted to give him a reward for
everything he has done for both ubisoft
and our communities
what else can we say well
i do appreciate the company so you
should come and join us you know i'm a
big fan of ubisoft i know a lot of
people give ubisoft grief but i i would
i would say i would have a very high
percentage of ubisoft games in my
library
you know it would be
a lot of games that i have i buy from
them
if you're just joining us you're
watching the ubisoft board pre-show in
just a little bit we'll have trailers
and announcements about your most
anticipated titles to share with you but
before we get to mario plus rapid sparks
of hope and skull and bones we still
have a couple of more announcements to
share with you check it out
hey everyone we are from the annual team
based in ubisoft mines creators of the
beloved annual city builder series our
latest title annual 1800 transports you
to the age of industrialization
it challenges you to go grand cities
manage a complex economic system and
logistical network and deal with
competitors through diplomacy or
military means
use your fleet to settle on multiple
islands create trade routes and expand
your empire in different regions
in our current season four we're
expanding the new world region of annual
1800 with new content and stories as
well as standalone scenarios for special
challenges
our new world rising dlc will complete
that expansion with an individual
population here
new productions
monuments
new islands explore okay
first glimpse like our upcoming con
today so check out this first teaser and
make sure to visit the annie union
website for more info
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we've all been there
in the midst of battle
at the heart of the race you know people
can say what they want it's like you
said they
on top ubisoft does try
yeah
they take risks
and i love that i love that about
ubisoft man i really do
i wish a lot more uh but some of us
feel the need develop i wish a lot more
of these publishers would take more
risks
together perfect shot
so chat
tell me what you guys think they're
going to end this with around
what what
what project do you think they're going
to end ubisoft with before we go
around our table i'm going to mute this
real quick uh so they can just hear us
smooth what do you want them to end this
with and what do you think they're going
to end this with
you're going to end with i want them to
end with like a splitter though
um
i want to see prince of persia again
okay what about uk mega what do you want
them to end this with and what do you
think they're going to end this with
i would want them to uh ended with um
uh
prince of persia would be really dope
but um i i would like to see them show
the uh
dlc to the the last dlc to uh donna
ragnarok or i would say the odin saga
from assassin's creed valhalla
um
but i think what they what i think what
they all end with is probably the last
uh assassin's creed of this new
assassin's creed that's most likely
probably going to go back to the
original
uh old-school way of assassin's creed
middle east
uh shout out to the chat middle of it so
they could end with a microsoft buyout
at the end
this let's go
yo imagine
if they announced that they're being
bought by microsoft
man oh my god i go straight to twitter
oh of course of course
uh now there's a possibility that there
could be uh
some uh announcements yeah game pass
announcements uh if not like maybe the
ubisoft store uh coming to xbox now you
know that would be i think that would
that would be pretty amazing so
um you know but
i think that's not too far from
uh reality but man good grief well if
they did that i am definitely i'm i'm
cutting the xbox off i'm going to sit
back and watch twitter for the rest of
the evening
uh because because it's going to be it
would be uh
it would be fantastic
it would be delicious
[Music]
is this that game that i see people
always be
putting in on tick tock
uh what is this track mania
i don't know clue what this is
i think it was track
that's far cry
yeah that's far oh you're the bad guys
if you ever played far cry 6 i would
definitely recommend it it's really good
i'm trying to be really
oh my god the farmer just ran over the
hostages
hostages are fun
yeah i mean
i i think i heard k megas speaking about
far cry 6. that was a good game
good game really good game yeah it was
really good
all right oh my god
[Applause]
yo
that was actually very skillful
oh going through the uh with the plane
like that yeah that was though
um i wonder how many times it took him
to do that
took him a lot another game too that i
think a lot of people should go out and
uh play is a for honor for honor is so
much improved um compared to when it
first launched
[Music]
six years ago
six years ago but yeah it's it's greatly
improved it's really really fun the
games you've just seen in the pre-show
you can try them for free on pc starting
right now for a month on ubisoft plus i
like the sound of free now don't run
just
time for our main show you won't want to
miss this so let's kick things off
i mean you know kind of probably
following the ea trend until he
got it right and started putting ea
access and now ea play on the console
maybe
see the light
hopefully
he's probably giving me a copyright
claim right there
hi everybody thank you so much for
tuning in to the september edition of
ubisoft forward the showcase where you
get a taste of all the great things
we're cooking up i'm one of your hosts
neelam kumar i'm yusuf mageet and i'm so
happy to be here today because this year
we're global streaming in no less than
11 different languages so a big hello to
everyone around the world we're also
live in four sign languages and two
audiences i think yeah 2021
between twenty twenty one twenty twelve
uh a lot of ubisoft time now come along
from being interested
look at us hey
look at us look at us who would have
thought not me so let's get to the real
reason why we're here today games
the only thing i don't like about these
is you should already be caught up in
some super exciting updates from current
releases it feels like and now always
the holster and like made to go we're
live
to run the
show the way ubisoft does and like i
always felt like host
that's what i like about greg miller
like
when greg miller hosts the show
you generally feel like him doing it you
know what i'm saying like a lot of the
hosts it just feels like they're reading
like a script and they're not really
going off of it too much catching up
with the assistant right right
but we also wanted to remind you that
right now you're all eligible like if
this was greg saying this tell me greg
wouldn't be doing this more like
funny-wise you know what i'm saying like
oh yeah yeah yeah you can kind of tell
you can tell when people are
off script and aren't on script yeah
this is definitely i mean you look at
their eyes fixated on this adventure
instead of
on nintendo switch before we catch up
with the game's creative director davide
soliani let's take a quick look
[Music]
i didn't like the first one i'm not
gonna lie to you guys
oh rabbits yeah
i yeah
i'm not it's not my thing
i bought it for my kids many moons ago
hello everyone
a few months ago we gave you an
exclusive on mario plus rabbit's sparks
of all
showcasing the game's unique mix of
turn-based combat
real-time action
and open exploration
we also did a deep dive on our unique
team of heroes
i want to thank you so much for your
tremendous feedback
and i know
you now want to see more gameplay
so today we it's not just that jeff
i feel like the majority of hosts that
every event feels like they're talking
on screen
like that they only really contract them
because of like who they are in the
community if they have a following like
they don't really care about their
personality if that makes sense
[Music]
hello everyone i'm faye associate
producer welcome to this new video about
mario plus rabbids sparks of hope
today our heroes travel to terraflora in
their quest to save the sparks
someone's gonna end up making my ass
reviews
we've been trying to do better on
reviewing nintendo games i'm gonna try
to avoid this one though
i feel like i've reviewed a couple of
nintendo games this year i'm gonna
review pokemon that's good that's good i
don't need to do anymore
i'm gonna make sure when king gets in
here i'm gonna make sure that you said
that you told me i didn't you said you
wanted to do this i'm gonna yeah i think
smooth is gonna pull the volcano
on that like so i think that you need to
try this game out let us know
what you think
i'm going to play 10 minutes of it just
to get 10 minutes of gameplay and just
[ __ ] on it
it's packed
if i have to review it i'll review
affair
i just didn't like the turn base they
had last time
with the help of people heroes can
interact with the environment in various
ways to uncover secrets or reveal a
hidden path to new zones
there are many interesting places to
visit and secrets to discover on
terraflora
giant trees lush plains and hidden caves
but let's get back on track
we have a train to catch
all aboard
what is going on
[Music]
oh
[Music]
who's this dude with all the hair
i don't know
i mean it's it's a cute game
i would definitely like it would be
something maybe my wife would definitely
play because i mean she's into if she
does play this obviously you want to
play games this would be it
so this is acg's most anticipated game
of the year
oh god i'm like
i don't know acg if that's true
the weaver has been enraged why is
bowser always considered like one of the
most beast people in mario stuff until
it revolves him being on your team
because he was a monster in browser's
world or whatever that that last uh
mario game with browser
turns into big ass like godzilla-looking
creature all right so i like themselves
i like how they've changed the ui
heroes focus on the darkness eyes look
at mario and the team to take advantage
of his great mobility skills
now the sparks there are dozens of
sparks you can pair with your heroes
they will grant elemental damage
resistances help control battlefield and
much more okay so there's a lot more
stuff going on in this one
[Music]
we're done prepping so now is the time
to fight
let's activate mario spark aquanox to
gain additional splash damage thanks to
his flash effect
uh bone is right he said uh ubisoft is
the only company outside of nintendo to
touch mario yeah you know i didn't
really think about that but he's right
robert rosalina
no that's bandai yeah that's band batman
makes smash breaking new enemies
uh yeah
uh i never knew that project sold the
the team that makes uh soul calibur
they're the ones that work on
[Music]
uh
smash bros let's use mario spark glitter
i am so sorry i do apologize signature
abilities for my tardiness
[Music]
why does kids move have that face what
is he looking at
that his face is turned up in such a
manner
playing 2k 23. okay so it didn't start
yet
it's mario rabbids just though i'm not
here
he said you might as well
the hotness hasn't started
all right
and mario
we're watching it on twitch
uh youtube
youtube part cool
teamwork
sorry for uh
you know you know what's funny just uh
just some people now
king used to do our reaction streams
watching our reactions
won't be easy yo and what's funny is i
was just about to do that right now shut
up
ubisoft has their own um joint or are
they going through ign or somebody
oh they got their own joint their own
yeah but you can go you can go look
through it through like you know
the other
places like ign and stuff no i don't do
that so at least the sparks give a
little more like variety
the reason why i don't do that because
that's why i was direct competitive so
you know um
no ah they don't they don't get that
love for me like that
i want i want all eight editors on loads
of gaming.net if y'all listening
there's a home for you
yeah bro come on come on
yo i was just watching um
a video you put up the other day uh
yeah yeah kind of spicy but mario oh
yeah
a little spicy a little spicy
sometimes i get a little spice
i definitely like it i definitely like
it appreciate it everybody has to be
vocal you know these dudes think we're
we're vocal against uh
stuff just because no we're we're vocal
because we are part of the whole
collective so we weren't we didn't start
at a playstation 4 like a lot of dudes
oh yes
this is delicious
it looks great i mean you know for what
it is like i was saying my wife would
would be all over this i'm saying this
isn't it i'm saying something that i
would like
on
don't lie don't cap cause i played the
first one and i thought the first one
was outstanding i'm not even gonna lie
from from from a cover shooter strategy
uh type of um x-com type of game i
thought they had all the bells and
whistles knocked down and um to be
honest with you so
to see this the second one and they did
it so well they had so much care with
the first one that i know they're gonna
have that same level of kid with the
second one for you all so do this i
don't have no problem with it
it looks way better though the only way
i would review rabbits is if we got a
review code because i i'm not i'm not
rushing through that game
will not stop at lunch we have so it
looks it looks really good even though
they got this guy superimposed
in the screen
right about now
it looks it looks really good
nintendo's knows their limitations and
they don't stray too far away from it
right you don't see them reaching too
high so you don't see a bunch of popping
hair or texture or wavy hair
or stuff like that and they know
if it's going to be 60 frames per second
you know you're gonna get a pretty bland
uh picture so they go for that
you know 30 frames per second type of
thing nice draw distance
i don't have no problem with it to be
honest with you
no i mean the games
the games run perfect on
like you said they know their
limitations you know i'm saying they
they know their hardware really well
they don't try to push the limits nope
and we always talk about you know the
the you know microsoft or sony's uh
development tools
we never give credit to nintendo for the
development tools because their
development tools must be some of the
greatest things on the face of this
planet that they're engineers because to
get some of the stuff running on their
consoles
it's insane
no doubt rayman is in there
oh
oh that's cool i love the rabbits and i
love the world of mario and i'm so glad
here we go again davide is so passionate
about what and i can't wait to play as
rayman on my team in this new dlc
adventure if you like what you just saw
and want to dive into the conversations
online just use hashtag you before yeah
we're covering both his and hers
like when they were talking about the
languages and all that
yeah you know like and they got people
in with sign language they want to make
sure that everybody
remember this is the sea of these
killers
well no this is the god of war killers
because they come out on they like what
up
what up
i heard you was launching this day dogs
that's some drinking to celebrate my
facts
i didn't know that we were having some
slander today i thought it was supposed
to be peaceful i thought no man anytime
i'm in the building
on deck
[Laughter]
i told you i drink sony tears
here we go we got it in the five gallon
bottles now oh yeah these chairs it's
secret
you know we're paying the big bucks for
that big bucks for the tickets
that's right
that's right
what beyonce say put a little lemon in
there
lemonade
that has like nothing to do with tom
clancy or anything yo
i love this super imposing these people
in the game
and if you're ignorant you're gonna
think that's the graphic
this is where you and your friends what
they're trying to do is
consciously make you feel like
since they're in the world that like
real life is the grass
she's gonna go there and pick up an
apple and start eating it
i'll pass out
she said for sure now i'm gonna tell you
this game is so realistic look at me
that'll look good
wait a second
wait
oh
we talk about a new game versus dlc
that's what they talk about right there
this is a new game versus dlc
so king building
are you confident or less confident that
god of war's coming out this year i'll
give you the opportunity right now to
bend the knees
this game is shipping this game don't
care about what you talking about what
i've been doing let's look at what we're
looking at here
we're looking at a game
this is a showcase for a game that's
coming out this year that i'm confident
is showing up i ain't getting a showcase
for that other thing now that dlc should
have had a showcase already revealed
again it should have
yeah
so i don't care to give up my knees if
it do come out it's just going to be a
surprise
surprise who do you see
all of you out
[Music]
maybe one or two different locations
they got two ogres now one with horns
and without surprises
with stripes
that is what we want for our parents
[Music]
november 8th what's good
this is definitely what i'm talking
about i like i get to choose my own
canon
step 2
now all i got to do is allow me to
choose my old crew
like you can do it um
because i was i was pulling up with some
of the grimiest dudes you've ever seen
in your life
hell
casey jones lock-up
dangerous look at this this looks nice
we clowned it when it first showed up we
was like who want this who asked for
this
apparently we did
apparently
i ain't no i needed this it looks like i
need it
hey solve i hope you're watching i i
need to review this
yeah i definitely will play it that's
that for sure i mean i'm gonna put some
work i don't know if it's going to kill
sea of thieves if we got the slave dance
we got to have a slave dance now if it
ain't got the slave dance with the old
i don't know yeah they're not making it
i don't know i don't see it
it would be definitely a game that i
think that will be long-lasting what
this reminds me of is uh
for honor like it's for honor then i
don't think did very well when it first
came out but yeah but then it just
progressed and i think this is this is
one of those type of games and he'll
eventually start catching on man can we
say right now that ubisoft is not one to
give up on games
yeah absolutely because this game we all
thought this game was dead on arrival
was dna
and you know what i'm saying because i
mean when we went to that e3 what was it
five six years ago yeah we went up there
we were like okay cool but who asked for
this yeah yeah yeah and they just kept
toiling away at it same thing with for
honor yeah you got are you guys uh
buffering or yeah we buffering somebody
you know god of war ddosted yeah yeah
two good graphics look too good man you
got god of wars like yo hold on man
that's not dlc mike pump your brakes
pump your brakes
[Music]
what is this riders republic wait
remember that game oh yeah i got that
game that game is fire oh so this is
this is a part two or something yeah
this must be an expansion there's just
an expansion probably
oh okay so this is dlc
yeah because this game came out uh in
september last year i will watch it on
twitch if anything
yeah
no it's going right now
they've been back
this game is fun as hell man like out
last night when i was doing grg i was
showing gameplay
[Music]
yeah like a little jet pack suit and and
parachute and skateboarding and all that
yeah like it's a snowboard
this was definitely thinking out the box
when it came to extreme sports right and
this is why i this is what i was saying
the attic before you came in here was
like ubisoft uh you know so this is i i
got so many ubisoft games in my library
yeah you know i'm saying i'm a fan of
them and like addicts said like they
take chances they're not they're a
publisher that is not afraid to take
and i totally agree with that i i
noticed that you're not afraid of taking
chances they allow 10 cent to come in
and get 46 percent
that's a hell of a chance you're taking
it all right
they out there [ __ ] blocking pulse my um
my poor xbox y'all know y'all was next
on season four
yes sir
play free right now you heard that play
free if you saw something you like get
in there and the bmx add-on launches in
just four days on september 14th and
guess what i like that um
for free i like that jacket that he got
on
the big boy sizes
yeah
got my size
he could walk in walmart and just get to
see the shirt off the rack all right
that fit me
not me sir
oh buddy is that for your kids oh my god
for you
i don't see nothing that's your problem
right now they're busting guns i didn't
see anything
oh man i don't know what connection you
got
i don't know
she's talking right
i gotta join her twitter page
looking
now we want to retariate it
today it might be this long-term future
history i mean
you know
i'm developing that might be a guy
across the globe stop this
stop
go home
oh
[Laughter]
you need to refresh your choice don't
see the black screens you need to go to
another connection america
hopefully the streaming got a black
screen
and some updates from our studio here's
our creative direction all right so kids
which are your misinformation baby uh
what what do we see here
we're gonna
take care with us when we go outside now
all right kid let us know what's up
first
it doesn't look good man
[Laughter]
well you know what it kind of makes
sense
because uh division went free to play i
mean um um destiny went free to play
and uh division should have something to
you know to rebut that
i don't know how that model works for
this game but it works for destiny
you get the vanilla part and then you
get hooked
as long as the division's gone
[Music]
he's challenged oh it just came on all
of a sudden oh never mind it went back
are you being swatted right now
the team is hard at work preparing what
comes next yeah
your feedback has been priceless i'm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no you don't
yo i say that all the time shout out to
my boy hot loving monkey hot monkey's
loving it oh that's where it ended on
mobile
this is a mobile game
[Music]
experience
this is going to be day one xcloud i can
tell you that oh yeah
the clock is ticking
if you ain't got a cell phone that can
play this stop watching now
if you still got that flip from from 86
[Music]
you got that razor
ain't going to work on the razor the
razor kishi
oh i know
crab what you can
yeah grab a double battery cause she
won't melt out two seconds
this is what god of war riding rocket
looks like
laid out like that until next year
i can't wait till they got god of war
moving imma pee on myself
get out if you can game back uh
what uh god of war mobile yeah they had
a god of war mobile game back in the
days um trust no
yeah
you talking about the psp version or the
veto no it was a it was a mobile phone
game like oh oh okay okay
oh we gotta pull that dirt up i need
that dirt for sunday
if you want to get a chance to test it
out don't forget that word for me
sweet multiplayer action in the palm of
my hands speaking of which there's
another iconic i bet you guys dude i bet
you this dude don't even play games on
mobile like that like jim ryan
[Music]
get my material ready for tomorrow
rainbow six mobile another mobile game
this is mobile mondays
it should have been on the monday show
over the weekend because yesterday it
was all a lot of mobile on the on the uh
dsd showcase yeah we gotta give that to
jeff
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah i don't know why they doing this
all this mobile stuff are people really
adapting games like oh yeah mobile like
mobile is
is bigger than pc right now probably in
um
eastern asia
and stuff like that um
because at no point in time do i see a
dude walking through the mall or online
you know well you know with his mobile
phone now
contraption
i just don't see that happening i see
dudes that they switch and stuff like
that i've seen two steam machines you
know uh it's steam decks
i have never seen nobody with a cell
phone out rocking earlier you know
playing the full it was amazing to see
how our players in community
rainbow six mobile is a free-to-play
game designed from the ground up
specifically for mobile devices
when we started production our objective
was crystal clear to bring the rainbow
six universes
i know i'm talking about the
whatchamacallit today i'm talking about
the mandalorian three and all that stuff
oh no did they have more
because i was thinking like oh man
that's the only thing that god did you
know i think that's going to be decent
but and it's whatever today and i like
the racing card games yeah because we
haven't had a good like mario kart uh
clone type game in a minute the close
beta starts this monday
i don't care about that i'm talking
about the actual show
can still produce actual show stuff that
they're talking about today
they're blowing up the internet just a
quick note for ios users don't worry
that's why half the people is not here
that's my kid falling asleep because we
want to know who the hell is playing uh
what can you expect to see in the game
during debate
our biggest addition is the first stage
of our opportunity he's going to be the
next black panther he's trying to figure
it out challenges to complete a take
assistant to play with i was excited
about players even though it was even
trailer of tron but it made me excited
about yeah it's going to be a tron
and game plan i love the last stream
social features like voice chat and
persistent teams they're going to do it
when they did the remake of it you will
also be able to compete in three icons
you know basically what they did they
just did an updated version get people
to get back into the world of trump
still a work in progress so i was happy
because i grew up on
content and to go back and see what it
looked like compared to what we did now
as we continue along this exciting road
to release we must go forward alongside
yeah we do our players that and blade
runner we believe those movies that were
made in time that blade went on
clockwork orange those
now
you may be wondering in which countries
the closed beta will okay so we're in a
space right now monday where we're
lathering you guys up and getting these
guys ready for what we really want to
drop off
now we don't board you to death we got
kids smooth with the kids move face
looking at the screen
you get their face like i can't believe
i'm still here
somebody give me a red bull
rainbow six game yeah rainbow six um
mobile
[Music]
you ready to breach mobile phones
this is exactly what it is because ain't
nobody graphics look like this so this
is definitely somebody's mobile phones
do not do that there's no cap this is
mobile all day if you don't tell me this
is series s i'll throw this out the
window right right watch i bet you
somebody would post it and try to make
it out yeah
yeah
this is the playstation 5.
oh
30 frames a second cinematic style
told you rainbow six mobile
we're gonna breach your phone pause
you'll be laying on your bed here clear
what the hell
dude start climbing out of your phone in
your bed
target spotted oh what the hell is going
on
wow uh
spotlight said jesus christ
you want somebody to give you the code
to the nukes tie them up to a chair and
force them to eat five popeye biscuits
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
exclusive to netflix
no it's the
[Laughter]
if you can play games through netflix
watch what i tell you and it's
true
watch what happens thank you watch
people are watching the text yeah
netflix said they was getting into the
the gaming business so i mean
you know because
[Laughter]
i know who not being sold
surprise brother you
this is where the magic happens this is
it
that's the fear though that's the real
thing
it was what i said last night
let's just be reasonable i said it's
funny because
you know playstation has been getting
microsoft
you ain't calling your broke friend you
got troubles who are you calling me
you're not calling your broke friend who
in the same pool as you you know what
his finances smell like right
he got caught trouble just like you
calling him they said we see where the
castle is green on the other side nah
they calling who got cash you got who
you know
i don't care what happens all i'm
waiting for that morning i'll wake up or
boom call me an apple
sunny with that 12.99
[Laughter]
[Music]
happy hour
what happened when 10 cent come in and
slide in your dms right
this soon as dan saint got up in there
they start talking movies mobile
let it be baby let it be
they got you doing all types of apple tv
they walling right now
he said i don't know what just happened
jim
back to you
in existence or more of a casual fan
there's something for everybody
for sassy
[Applause]
this is only the beginning
yeah man be careful what you wish for
boy it happens it happens it happens in
the blink of an eye life comes at you
fast
[Music]
yeah we buy sony what's the first thing
you do if microsoft by sony no i said
iop bought sony what was the first thing
you would do first of all i'd be really
upset that we got 68 billion dollars in
the background and i ain't getting paid
yet you ain't got it
where did that come on hold on hold on
i'll be so mad
[Laughter]
a lot of free games in a wonderful i'll
show right now
as soon as we buy them i'll sell
straight to microsoft pennies
oh my god i called phillip myself
oh so delicious oh my god i'm like
listen listen i'm ready to sell right
now but you just got him 58 seconds ago
i'm ready to sell
i'll sell them on a discount right now
you know what i'm saying think about it
think about it phil think about it he
ain't even got to think about it
everything on game passes
oh my god i don't know who's angry at
him in his chair
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh man what is
this look like
yeah
really popular game it's really popular
on pc all right there we go
well that looks nice you know like a
whole lot of ray tracing what did
is the screw why is it just popping up
in front of me
oh no hell no what's all this pop-up
no no no
that gotta be for mobile
track mania mobile
[Music]
welcome to the club
consoles and cloud platforms oh
you already know where that's going
and streaming let's stay away from us
the first bit of good news is stay away
from them we'll be available across all
platforms
[Music]
we have lots of features to keep you
racing you like that scissors
three months
don't
[Laughter]
sorry kid see you next
oh man sony santa monica is going to
send a note give me some traction
this is like asgard it just ain't going
to get there
necessary
uh moving on let's jam out to our next
release
oh man
[Laughter]
plus
over 10 years of rocksmith plus learner
guitar
bass millions of people
[Music]
and none of them is in this podcast
no
so listen
when you're on the train and you want to
annoy the hell out of yeah yeah
somebody sitting next to you pop open
your phone
and play rocks
every time you download it
they might as well say every time you
download a song smooth drink some nyquil
[Laughter]
let the dopamine drop
oh man every time somebody downloads
this game we give a bottle of tryptophan
to kiss me
drinking blood was eight nine to nine
but we're spending 50 giving it to we
spent thousands giving votes
if you're going to learn guitar you
should also practice your dance moves
there's a bottle just a thing there sir
which makes me want to boogie how could
i forget turn it off these are so crazy
dance
i thought you liked the just ass game
be back baby like dance central when
they connect with a lot
yeah something to make you really do
something oh they threw a ball on their
floor with eyeballs
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
homegirl was literally just kidnapped
like
and nobody said anything no no the whole
yeah
left the friends i had to i had to mute
the uh the stream because uh clearly
this is copyrights
right
hey it's move
no we wiggle
now push
now get it now
i'm gonna take my captain to another one
but you know what king can we we don't
have a member's goal where he
where we got we got to synchronize and
do a just dance song
that ain't happening oh god in there we
are not doing this
hey
hey
now back boogie now back who really do
these moves now
right like
this yeah but this is uh oh man yeah
they still doing the running man stop
but you know we catch these dudes right
up in packs and they be doing fortnite
dances on the floor i ain't gonna lie i
saw it myself with both my eyes
when you put it out there at e3
oh it's more just dance talk
about real people in clubs just dance
has been yeah so so hold up king king so
how's your day been well my dad's been
really rosy but this is what they talk
about right now they talk about the new
dance dance revolution central stuff
oh man you got a super chat uh flame
passionately
got a two dollar supercharge from flame
channel for a just dance video thousand
dollars it is nothing so whoever asked
that question you know what i'm going to
tell you right don't let me find you
because i won't hurt you
i mean everything they show and got two
stars
oh my god how did they let that go on
stream
yeah for starters king house
dance who's gonna pay a thousand dollars
to adjust to him
okay i don't care because i'm not doing
it
and i'm not putting myself in it i was
the idiot with the hot chip challenge
until everybody could get a hot chip in
their mouth
i don't care no more
i literally died and died again
and i had to get a tattoo hell with
these people shout out to will
muted the stream into this just dance
nonsense you're going to talk we going
to have a different conversation
challenge really what they doing over
there but i i did i used um kid for
reference right this kid is a pioneer
kid kid did that first you know from the
streamers he did that first and i saw it
and i was like damn man did you see what
smooth put the mouse pad in his mouth yo
he was going crazy he was going crazy
and i can tell you right now you guys
move you can act smooth right now would
he ever do that again hell no no
absolutely not no okay yo you know
what's move they don't tell you about
the second time then when it's coming
out
they don't tell you about that
they don't tell you about that that's no
and you feel it for days after yo nobody
tells you see because when i did it you
know and and
everybody gonna watch and they'll be
like nah i can't i don't even really
think you took the chip because i was so
smooth with it no cool i knew exactly
what to drink as as somebody that was uh
smart in science i understood exactly
what to drink and it's not milk and it's
not water damn sure don't put no no
dairy in your mouth and you're not going
to put no water because water only makes
you more thirsty to be honest with you
if you all understand the dynamics of it
so i was drinking pure squeezed lemon
water yeah lemons just lemon lemon juice
like actually real you know they're
spending a lot of time on this yeah well
because they want to sell it to you well
it's a very popular game too yeah it's
hugely popular twisted yes man so if i
can catch you dancing the lady gaga i'm
gonna definitely go rah-rah-rah i'm
gonna get you i'ma get you
you'll be surprised i'll pay i'll find
some money from some place my dollar
super chat from spotlight goes uh
ubisoft saw disney's turd fest from
yesterday and said we could do worse uh
hold our drink yeah so he look at him
he's still out here
his check must be good
yeah that's what they do man they they
pay these hoes such an absurd amount of
money they'll do anything at that point
you got to do it wherever you're outside
i bet you look at the floor
i bet you i bet you if they contracted
the iron podcast to host this it would
have been more entertaining
[Laughter]
watch tomorrow see y'all see the graves
right here right yeah tomorrow i think
it's going to be like magic we'll show
you where the brakes are in the future
and we even
okay can someone tell me what assassin
that is behind them thank you for the
yeah that's the one from the psp i mean
the vita created that's the old disaster
screen i don't care about the old
testament
that's that's the chick from the video
right that's that's you know
unity was the last one where you could
actually
do assassinations right
why why can't
why can't we see this dude just dance
you ain't got that
this is what we all came here for
that's very blame but let's hope they
fix it right here the assassin's creed
2020 all right let me see let me make it
big pause
they changed all the box art for all the
previous games by the way if i don't
know if you've seen it on your xbox they
just
dating all the way back to
i think
unity they all have different covers now
they don't like this gold is it like
gold yeah 13.
are you ready oh wait a second that
looked real as hell of course
that's the first assassin's creed
black flag is the best one black flag is
not the best one but back flag is dope
everybody
origins is the one that got me back into
it i got a personal bite
to make it right
or just made me go and play
and then play uh
syndicate yeah
what are they about to do this is
interesting well the the assassin's
creed infinite is going to be like in
the assassin's creed universe
well i haven't played violent playground
history leap into history
leap into your wallet
join the celebration
try it for free with ubisoft plus hello
everybody we're here to go into your
wallet where did they get all of this
stuff showcase it is time to leap into
history i'm danny wallace here in our
top secret hideout where are we going
special guests and sharing look at all
these statues all these little stats
you know they partner up with pcs no no
um
and got some statues
and those pure art styles ubisoft's own
oh my god they caused a pretty penny but
i thought i thought for a second he said
we're joined here by a true expert i
don't know why
who first appeared back in assassin's
creed ii now sean sounds exactly like me
that was there may give you a clue as to
the limits of my acting range this year
we are celebrating 15 years since the
release of everybody passed caps
though it's been an amazing journey with
our community that was a great rooftops
of the holy land
and odyssey is my favorite revolutionary
wars to ancient worlds mine is odyssey
and origin
i'm still tight i didn't finish
syndicate and i won a play phenomenal 15
years and we are so glad that you came
along for the ride i will say
origins
um unity for the 15 year anniversary i
gotta i gotta get to all um
celebrate with you our community
we know that you've been dying to find
out what's next for assassin's creed and
so
i just thought it'd be nice well i like
some of the dlcs like that uh atlantis
stuff but in uh
what's happening here it's the trailer
i've seen this game right
yeah don't you're ahead of us
you'll know about that
i think they meant they're going back to
the origins with like a story where
they're from a clan
[Music]
are you ready to leave your life behind
and walk the path of shadows they'll
probably break the templars and
assassins
then out of the dark you will come into
the light
you will return to the dark
[Music]
never forget the tenets you have sworn
to uphold
[Music]
stay your blade from the flesh of the
innocent
hide in plain sight
all the smoke from the original ones
yep
[Music]
[Music]
from this day forward
you are
a hidden one
[Music]
this does give me like real older
assassin's creed yeah they're going back
they're definitely going back
as i thought yeah mirage okay
yep right here that's the little light
scenes remember in the original one
where when he would kill someone he
would go into that other realm while he
would talk to them they would do that in
uh origins and
look at that assassin's creed mirage
everybody and here to tell us more about
is ubisoft bordeaux's narrative
directions i don't know
all of you thank you so much for coming
thank you for having me sarah we just
had a little glimpse of mirage what can
you tell us about this latest and very
special assassin's creed adventure well
indeed it is special we go back to the
roots of the series it's been 15 years
as you know and we wanted to go back to
the action adventure game that you know
narrative driven game
we've been focusing on stealth parkour
and of course assassinations
now i've been playing a lot of valhalla
recently and from watching that trailer
i couldn't help but notice bassine yes
you're right it's passive it's 20 years
before valhalla so it's a young vasim
that is going to be just like i said
street scenes
assassination uh fantastic and so where
does his kind of advancement coordinated
assassination okay so this is 20. they
said this is 20 years
that you're gonna roam through the
yeah it's a game dense city where you're
going to meet a lot of different people
that's amazing i know our community is
going to be very excited to explore
baghdad um so sarah what can you tell us
that makes mirage very special to you
specifically
but to me obviously it's all about the
story
did what he did to enter into the um did
he recognize the current day world war
it's actually right yeah
can i reveal it
that's what i'm saying like
you know you just wasn't it sure
it was it was kind of like you got it
right good yeah
somewhere down the line
he talked he talked he talked to a war's
brother
you know pretty much to
about the plan and that's why the
situations of valhalla turned into what
it did so
yeah and like basements like
that the way that that ended immediately
it's kind of cool i don't know
i wanted to kill that batson yeah like
he was a bastard but i mean that's what
i'm saying like i mean but i you know a
lot of people i'm pretty sure says
listen they lit ain't beat it so
when are we gonna get to
real game engine
right now it sounds like they're suppo
uh promoting newport the fact that she's
a mature woman from persian origins made
her resonate even more with my own story
and background
playing such a great that's all i'm
saying is cgi opportunity that i could
not miss
i hope somebody told you uh to turn down
the the strange volumes for me to
collaborate with the assassin's creed
brand and play one of the main
characters in such an anticipated new
game
i am wishing you all a happy ac 15th
anniversary
thank you all and it's a anniversary
kind of you know type of game so i can
understand it you know what i'm saying i
can get it
how long you don't think it's going to
be message
it's not going
assassin's creed mirage is going to be
available in 2023
and if you pre-order now you also get
the exclusive 40 thief side quest but
it's not all why would you pre-order you
don't even have a release date
it includes a figurine
it rubs
show me the graphics already
i beg of you please
stop showing me this uh this live stuff
i want to see the graphic are you
prepared to travel you're gonna look
like this
kinda
you saw one guy with a really big check
and another guy
this is yo this game
this game
i think this game caused this hardcore
parkour crap
people jumping in between
look at this i do not remember making
that decision they better not follow
sony's life and giving you a remake of a
remaster of a remake
yeah
you know they going for the 70 round
they bought their life
you saw that guy he had his call over he
thought that was jim ryan's younger
brother he did yeah he did
you got that whole face
we want the boat nut but the boat baby
on the orders of a single mad man
but act according to our own collective
i i can't lie though when you go to
these events
there's more people dressed up as
assassin creeds dudes
than any other like game franchise boy
and final fantasy
i think the only ones you could see it
be is like kitchen impact and overwatch
look at yeah
[Music]
they're doing all this cap and not
showing no game you're the best son
they're the best
they're the best that ever did it
this is the best stream ever said they
gave you a whole bunch thank you
good night
good night
seattle thank you
thank you for coming out we gave you
shoujo all our mobile games
[Laughter]
he said mother mother what's wrong kids
smooth i see dead people
i see no gameplay
how to finesse you
say yeah yo man i'm gonna put my money
down
oh my god
god
they capitalize on your fandoms so hard
showing people what could be done in
this game they show everybody they make
you have fomo i'm not a part of that oh
i need to have my little suit on i need
to do that too how can i be a part of
that and they showed you all the games
that you love and then they're trying to
sell you something new but don't
show you what they're trying to sell you
but tell you to go put your money down
that is the greatest finesse ever this
is the greatest one that's not just a
single setting in a single time
oh my
if y'all don't see it happening in front
of you guys man y'all are fools boy i'm
not gonna lie to you
you're gonna have to show them proof bro
show and prove beyond
they selling you a book in a netflix
movie
behind the scenes
they also got a collector's edition as
well they they made sure that they're
going to get premium maximum premium
dollars
but danny if you want more i've got
great news as we have more content so
we're going up against ragnarok
hey hey the other ragnarok was wild man
so i just so and after that got done
directed
this other one is going to be ridiculous
so i'm looking at you
continue to create new and exciting
things that look like the restaurant we
was in with high geeks we've already
released
activities into the world it actually
does
the dead series
mastery challenges and more recently the
road light forgotten saga today yeah
you asked me earlier i said i was hoping
that they would show this now they're
going to show it they're showing you
actual gameplay of the dlc that you can
actually get yes
super trap from world building fantasy
music kings
minds work so fast great streaming
we're gonna sail right across that river
no you're gonna swim it baby
playstation yes of course
make them pay more
but on xbox
we can get a nice you can fetch a good
40
that works for me
put the ruins in
let's go oh i'm all loaded i'm all on it
let's get it
read all the livestream
which nicely ties some of the storylines
established i'm not buying nothing as
soon as i do it's going to be in game
pass and i'm going to throw my
controller out the damn window like i
did immortal phoenix
you know like immortal phoenix friends i
love it i love it i purchased the game
and a week later it came out in game
pass and i wanted to throw
unless it's like something like a sony
game and they come out every five years
i'm good i'm of course i save money
mac thanks for joining us well thank you
alice it's great to be here and i i love
you xbox
thank you
for the community can you tell us what
makes us
so beloved as soon as i put my money out
i'll find out company as expressed by
eve is to enrich the lives of players
on assassin's creed we have a very clear
take on that mission i think
you know adding garnish to the food man
definitely man it's definitely a good
gold man what are you crazy
hell yeah
it's like the spread
i don't know what it is man all the
events this year has been trashed
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's it right there
yeah we get a call of duty stream before
we got that oh we didn't
understand the world
i'm just curious if they're going to
announce anything else or this is it no
this is it buddy
this is it
that's the closer you see him that's the
closer
they might have one more little snippet
or something like that
yeah that's the closer you put on that
two dollars
guys mirage is 50 bucks on its own yo
history is in this way but what does
this mean for fans going forward break
them well we want our passions
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
china one the china assassin's creed in
a mobile game the one that everybody's
been asking assassin's creed to do
yeah you wanna play it pull out your
iphone bye-bye anyway
pull out your galaxies get busy
[Music]
get that new razor out
[Music]
finessing what has been asking them to
do
um man
guess who heard you what division
then i got you son
no doubt it ain't gonna look nothing
like that
we hear you megan we hear you
yo that's the first time i've ever seen
someone promote the code name on screen
like that it looks amazing
[Laughter]
surprised
[Laughter]
wrap your mind around this one here
baby well it's still early in
development what everybody wanted you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna turn down
the uh
the audio
and you talk for him
so listen i'ma tell you a lot of us
people we sat back we heard you we heard
you talking [ __ ] and all right y'all
always wanted the china version right
well surprise
we did it
and we put all our muscle behind this
game i'm going to tell you it's nothing
like this in the industry at all
can you tell us a little bit about the
engine and how it runs king i'm curious
about what's going on with this game i'm
sure our fans are curious about it
ubisoft's never done nothing
well it's hot
well listen technically
i don't know king you don't sound too
confident in your words here can you go
a little bit more after this trailer
listen we got real dudes out in the
street playing on hops
[Laughter]
real musicians
it's coming in the gold foil with black
lettering iron lord style
if you can get her downloaded free
this is when uh this is when this is
when the uh the person that's there to
help out to help out the uh king is
going to whisper in his ear and he says
we'll be right back to let you know more
about that information right now listen
to this listen to this this sweet
symphony from whoever we're out of here
i'll be back yeah get out of here man
you are going to the wider world of
assassins
i i don't know where he was
fair to say but in the grand tournament
hold on one second as we peg him down
all right
okay let me tell you something this is
the greatest game for things to show to
you so and you will love it it's gonna
be 79.99
[Music]
japan
[Music]
i think the jade is going to be on
mobile and they're going to do one for
wow
from your point of view certainly the
community the fans have been asking for
for a long time so mac tell us more as
well well this is
direction of jeanette
players explore one of their most
awaited settings
um
um
this one for the switch
[Laughter]
resident evil
assassin's creed
star
switch
yo
what can you tell us about this project
they gave you the blair witch version
okay
this is
[Music]
you know
[Music]
you alice it's been a pleasure to be
here and to be finally able to share all
these great things that we have coming
for our fans
oh my god this is beautiful so to sum up
there are a lot of exciting things to
look forward to let's remind ourselves
of everything you can
right now
he's drinking right now hold on
baby
[Music]
which is exactly alice what i'm going to
do while we pass back
[Music]
forward
yeah we were so enthusiastic playing
that game i don't think that guy ever
saw that much action in that corner ever
you know
he was like yo we popping son we popping
well that does it for this no it's just
these two idiots
back he fun
i can't believe that that actually
what happened the prince of persia skull
and bones happened baby
uh
you got mirage that's the closest yeah
mario they got three good games i'm not
gonna lie the more real rabbits
um skull and bones
and um the the writers the um the
freestyle riders thing that was uh
radish republic yeah that was no real
with you i think that was the worst
event this year
oh no hell no no the worst event is the
event that didn't happen
oh see so you got to respect it you got
to respect even coming outside we can't
criticize if they don't show up you know
what i'm saying we got to keep on giving
them props so we gotta give them at
least a seven for showing up and showing
face what's
in the video that was worse than that
ah then i didn't put it out there now
disney's yesterday was pretty pretty bad
that was horrible but you gotta give him
a six for showing up
you gotta go
i gave him i wanted to be in the
tournament you gotta throw a punch
exactly we got to stop giving these
dudes passes for not showing up and
taking us for granted at least we're not
even talking about playstation you
brought playstation no i'm not saying
see i say a word i just said dudes that
give passes you already cast a mojo on
some dude head and it obviously got to
be blue
baby
disney was probably disney's definitely
worse but no no
i can't go with that bad man midnight
sons man i can't go with that man
midnight
that that that was what lifted it up to
a five yeah
yeah that was and it had game play they
they had a back trailer they showed you
who was going to be in the game they
showed up
we got 280 people in the chat hit that
like button put in the chat on a one to
tail ten scale what you guys feel like
that the scale was okay well i think
that's too big of a scale at addict give
him a wonderful time one to five no one
to ten we ain't gonna nah one to ten is
too big man pause
you gotta say one to five man you can't
be doing that you're doing that on
purpose so they got so they can skew
down to the lowest common denominator so
if it comes with a bunch of twos you
know it's doodle so you're gonna be
running with that we got a five out of
ten a two a three a four a six six a
five a five yeah man i give him a seven
for showing up oh yeah yeah i gave him a
seven right off the bat yeah yeah seven
seven for showing facebook seven you
know why the assassin's creed's a lot
assassin the assassin creed the the
ninja joint at the end that's cool you
gotta have uh skull skull and bones
all right um wario rabbits as much as if
you like it you don't like it it showed
well
you started off a show with a banger you
came in swinging right wario rabbits you
went straight to your main source then
you know skullenbones the game that's
going head to head with somebody that
might not even show up this year but
that's show face
out there
right right right is republic uh a
strong title it's up to its fourth
season
and it's giving you dlc then they showed
you dlc for valhalla to finish off a
story if you're invested you're right
you're right i'm giving it a five out of
ten right so then they showed you the
mobile games that you didn't care about
but somebody with a mobile phone or some
corner
said that's what's
i'm going to give it a 4 out of 10. what
about okay but what about uh the
division well oh you're right about the
division i'm going to give it a 3 out of
10. yeah see and then the division right
the free-to-play part for the division
right and then also the expansion to the
other division and they added mobile the
heart like the touchdown
yeah yeah
nah man you you breach and clear on your
cell phone mess up playing they showed
up they came with weird this is a five
six out of ten it's okay cool it's
better than a zero for not participating
when you came to class and you sat down
in your chair your teacher gave you
fifty percent of your score for being
there
right no matter
50 was up to you for what you showed
that's all that's all so you you show
face at it you pass
see if you don't come up you can't get
graded so i'm disrespecting all those
dudes that refuse to participate what
kind of schools did you go to that got
participation grades i went to i went to
that school that school in the hood i
wish
it was a gauntlet to get food did you
ever get 50 or a 50 just for walking
through the door in school
yeah
all right seriously yo you know let's
look at it we got the same skin tone i'm
joke
i'm jealous i'm jealous you be jealous
as you like it was a gauntlet to getting
clowns
the guns in the dark i actually had
i didn't just walk in
actually i felt library so uh you failed
libraries you had libraries
you had library as a subject
what what
how how you can't be quiet you loud
malfunction
quiet and read a book now you know what
i'm saying i'm not the same color as
king or uh or smooth but you i'm i'm in
between you know what i'm saying but i
still didn't know what are you talking
about what the hell are you talking
about library with a subject bro
you got a different school you see
yeah
and the reason i felt the library is
because it was it was first block
and i just used that as i don't have to
go to school don't say you didn't show
up
so you proven my point you don't show up
you fail thank you so much yeah
but i did show up to a lot of the
classes it just you know not all of them
not all of them right you see
so you took it for granted and you
failed
predominantly black schools is different
from i guess white schools yeah
that's nuts i never know that they had a
library as a class i've never had that
they went to the library to get uh those
micro fish so we can go back to class
exactly
i think technically it was called study
hall i think that's oh okay you fail
study i'm gonna shut you down oh no all
right close this mic shut them up
and that's that's 100 participation
that's all that is that is it show up
just show up again i was i was going to
do your homework i was a senior
and i would show up
at a second block every day almost every
day
i can't i can't i can't i refuse i can't
i can't take it and then some days i
would sleep through first block i still
had a three point something gpa so it's
not like
that
decimated me it's just you know that
that that class i i i see you said three
point something yeah that three point
something is very vague bro that could
be a three point one
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i wish i would have told my mom
she said what's your gpa three boys son
i love my teeth i lost all my teeth
right there because they're vague you're
playing with numbers here well i mean
clearly if you just show up and you get
fifty percent i mean that's you could
literally throw a rock and get the rest
like literally
[Laughter]
oh actually
someone said aba at least attic didn't
flunk home room or did he i didn't go to
home room yes he did he flunked he
flunked study hall home room his first
period is his homeroom home room no
room how am i how my school was is you
had first block homeroom second block
lunch third block and then fourth block
at home
i didn't come you wait sometimes i would
show up how many home rooms you had yo
second block some study hall
no no no
no first block which was my study hall
then room
then we went to uh to second block then
to lunch
and then third block to fourth block to
home oh wow like i would go home
oh go home
back to home
it was i i got like what's that thing
they call senioritis or whatever yo
i remember the first year my first
my first semester
like my first well yeah six months first
six months
in uh high school
they put me in with the wrong david
johnson i was in remedial classes
right so i'm in there with like 10
people in the room
i'm shacking it
yo i said this high school joint it's a
brief son
i'm like this math we did this math when
i was in the fourth grade this is
nothing i was killing it we had a
lunchroom like five times a day i'm like
this is butter so we have music class
then
i remember i'll never forget it they
came in the room they knocked and i knew
they were you know when somebody talking
about you but you you they don't they
don't say your name but they looking at
you i'm like what did i do i didn't do
i'm a star kid here man i'm a star kid
it's like yeah him i'm like okay
it's like oh yeah we mixed you up now
imagine this david johnson that was put
in advanced classes
[Laughter]
but he's supposed to be remedial so he
and they're going crazy punching
teachers in the face
you know what's funny uh it took him
when i was
when they put me in the class listen
they switched us back to our proper
classes
i said oh wow yeah this is this is high
school
when i when i was in uh when i was a
sophomore there was a dude that looked
almost like identical like me that was
in the same class
and how i was a vocational school so
like it was like a trade school that you
could go to instead of a regular class
but it was it was next door so you would
be in the lunchroom until it opened and
then you would walk over there so
after i found out that teacher keeps
getting him confused with me
he switched him up i started showing up
30 40 minutes late and then sometimes
and i know this is gonna sound really
bad
if i missed like half
the class and i would pop in i would say
i was him and he was me
so he would get the attendance and i
wouldn't and i don't know they never
figured it out like but you know i had a
good fail this dude
this dude right now working at
applebee's madison
i don't know man i don't know why i was
there
they kept
i'll be like dude you didn't correct
them it's not my fault like she took it
like what's funny is you have a snitch
shout out to him senior year because of
senior year because of the
it went over to study hall
because of study hall
it was looking like i didn't know if
everything was gonna go because uh they
were giving me a hard time graduating
because of study hall
what's funny is everyone was cloudy with
like yo how you go about how you about
to get in trouble for failing study hall
and everyone's about to graduate
so
i so then they finally okay just let
them graduate because i had enough
credits it's just
i don't know they were just really upset
that i wouldn't go to study halls
so it was what was funny is the morning
of graduating
i overslept
and it was it was like so no no it gets
worse it gets worse so it's like it's
like 9 30 and we walk at like 10 10 30.
and
my uh my friend sarah she called uh
my uh english teacher walks by and she's
like she hands her a hand out and she's
like what do you want she's like call aj
and give me your phone
so she they call me like over and over
again she has like eight people calling
me and so i finally pick up and she's
like we are sitting here in line waiting
for you and if you don't get here
immediately i was like jesus i had to go
there i was literally putting my tie on
in line going out to get my diploma wow
my mom's going to stomp my chest oh
no doubt
should have clapped my ears together
all right like my mom would have gotten
off work and made sure that i man
my mom was in arizona at the time so
yeah everybody would have been there
anyway dragging me out the bed anyway
yeah i would have already yeah my mom
might have took off work just to make
sure for sure because that's the next
because that's the next phase get grab
graduate and get you know i think out of
this house
goodbye no no
actually
the rehearsal you had to go to the
rehearsal to walk i was late for that
too all right okay so the stream is over
we had a good time it was fantastic
shout out to you we saw for even
participating and giving us something to
talk about be good or be a bad it's
actually happened all right so uh to the
next stream where we actually see some
gameplay from something hopefully that
thing actually hits you know the stuff
that we're talking about and looking for
and if not if they cap all the way to
that game what are you talking about
some blue boys the boys in blue
snitching on you you know who we talking
about
hashtag stop snitching listen kids i'ma
tell you publix public service
announcement stop snitching don't be
like your man jim snitching is bad
snitching actually does not serve any
purposes it might get you jump snitches
get stitches
and that's one to grow on so
all right so so k mega where can the
people find you
oh man i appreciate it man had a good
time as always man with you fellas um
you know uh but you can catch me on uh
on my channel okay make a 405 i also uh
stream
on twitch by the same name k mega 405 uh
we'll be doing fight night tomorrow
night we'll be playing some of that jojo
bizarre adventure come and check us out
doing that uh i do it late at night i
started like uh about eight thirty nine
yep central time ten o'clock i'll be
seeing this dude on yeah yeah yeah um
and then also um
on twitter at kmega4 you know what i'm
saying the slander that i drop is
usually delicious um you know what i'm
saying and i could just play i can just
show me playing
or beating a japanese game shout out to
atlas for dropping uh
soul hackers too i i got that done and
completed in the in the stands go crazy
and lose their minds
and they're talking about how much of
the sale instead of them showing some
game play and celebrating his gamers i
don't know man it's crazy out there in
the game streets but i appreciate it man
come and check me out in those places
man what about you kid smooth you got
anything going on
or do you gotta defend that do you have
a bet
do you have a bet with k mega are you
about to lose uh playing you're playing
madness
i mean everything's gonna apply i just
wanna
play i mean i don't go back to back man
you're gonna stream it
uh if he wants to um
yeah i mean yeah i don't mind um i'm
just bored and i thought i was gonna do
a reaction vid but ain't nothing to
react to
so
um but yeah man not going on um
i still got to send tired uh
the last of us in this capture card but
wow
um yeah man just
follow me on twitter subscribe to
youtube i'll try to find an excuse to
put out something um and and i might be
streaming
against okay mega
shout out to ilp attic
king david thanks for having me i
apologize i kind of got half my uh
hours they said it's good to get what
eight hours of sleep got seven more to
go so
[Laughter]
what about you king anything going on
with you
well um we're supposed to
have uh ufc on tonight i don't do ufc
so i'm going to watch nate diaz and
hopefully he can close the show
um i always like a nate diaz fight you
know the bronxton boys uh smacking
people love that stuff uh
you're gonna catch me on
what um
fortnite
fortnite yeah you gonna catch me on for
tonight later on today i've got to
finish up some stuff i got to do some
shows we got some painting to do
a couple other things around the house i
got to do put together some tables all
that other domestic stuff on a saturday
gonna have me some sangria have a good
time
and you can catch me on iop tomorrow
talking about them boys in blue knowing
they doing snitching on you be careful
because they're out here pointing you
out actively even though you have you
know confidential agreements
behind closed doors these boys are still
out there acting the full so definitely
catch us on ilp tomorrow 1pm i think
this is the last sunday
before we have to switch time and i'm
not looking forward to it at all
so we have a five dollar superchat from
tikkus uh assassin's creed mirage is
49.99 i thought games were supposed to
go up in price not down
we'll have to see if the next assassin's
creed is 50 they they might put that at
50 because it's like a spin-off or
something i don't know uh but i put uh
i'm gonna put mine in king's uh twitter
in the chat definitely go follow us on
twitter uh keep in mind i'm like three
followers away from four thousand
followers so yeah so some people come
over here and follow me on twitter let's
let's get that let's get that for that
4k
uh we also have 129 likes i think we
should i think that should have been
higher i'm just saying just say you guys
want to do this reaction but you won't
like the video no i'm joking you guys
can like the video if not i don't care
right now i'm watching disney man i'm
i'm not gonna even cap i'm not even
gonna hold them they're gonna watch us
later they're gonna catch the jokes
later but that man delorean three trill
i haven't seen it
shout out to my boy young grogu we
outside baby
he right there too
no i'm uh
i'm referring to like the the games
after mirage like see if it does go
continue that fifty dollars i hope it's
fifty dollars that would i doubt it very
seriously sir i i hope it is i doubt it
very seriously but i appreciate ever
coming through
wario's rabbit is not gonna be 50 bucks
no i think he's talking about assassin's
creed yeah well i mean that's part of
ubisoft's stuff to be honest with you i
think the like you said the mirage is
probably a special case for something we
got to figure why it's like that um but
there's a reason why it's like that you
know for that price it probably doesn't
have as much to give to be honest with
you because i didn't see anything from
it to be honest with you to be real you
know i saw a lot more of the mobile
stuff
and and i'm pretty sure that they
they're going to be priced accordingly
no i didn't see anything from mirage at
all nothing
yeah uh so appreciate we're coming
through and we'll see you tomorrow on
the iron lords podcast 1 p.m eastern
you're not going to want to miss king
uh he he he definitely got a he's got a
gospel to tell you guys some warming up
right now
oh me